Bitte schön.
Okay.
Danke.
Guten Tag, my name is Ustoo.
Ich bin der Erste, der ich immer zu Hause habe.
Wer ist okay für Sie?
Ja, ich habe natürlich klar.
Okay.
Ich werde erst, ihr reparationiert,
Okay? Ja, natürlich.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Rudolf Pol.
Rudolf?
Und Nachname?
Mit Familiennamen Pol. Puhl.
Puhl. Pol.
Rudolf Pol. Hab ich richtig?
Ja.
Herr Pol, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 57.
57, gut. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. Mai 65.
65, gut.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,82 Meter.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie denn?
Ungefähr 90 kg.
90 kg.
Ja, Herr Pol, was für Bescheid haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen halten?
Ich sehe Sie.
Ja, ich habe solche schrecklichen Hüften.
Und ich habe auch ganz hohes Fieber.
Zwischendurch habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht gut Luft bekomme.
Und mein Kopf tut mir weh.
Und wenn ich husse, das tut mir hier im ganzen Großbereich.
Das tut mir alles weh.
Und jetzt habe ich gedacht, ich kann nicht mehr.
Das strengt mich alles so an.
Ich muss jetzt doch mal hier ins Krankenhaus kommen.
Ja, Sie haben einen guten Schritt gemacht, Herr Pol.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bescheide?
Ja, eigentlich seit einigen Tagen.
Ich will Sie ja seit 5 Tagen.
Da hat das angekriegt.
Sind Ihre Bescheiden pfioslich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Na ja, also mit dem Husten das fingen wir einmal an.
Und dann ist es aber jetzt immer schlimmer geworden.
Und mit dem Fieber, da habe ich mal gestern Abend
eigentlich das erste Mal gemessen.
Ich habe mich zwar immer heiß gefühlt, aber es ist ja auch warm draußen.
Und dann habe ich aber gemerkt, dass ich richtig glühe.
Und dann habe ich gesehen, dass ich fast 39 Temperatur habe.
39, okay.
Haben Sie dabei auch Ausfluss?
Ja, da kommt so ein ekliges grün-gelbes Zeug raus.
Das ist ganz unangenehm.
Und wie sagt die Ausfluss aus?
Ja, so gelblich und grünlicher schlagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie gegen diese Bescheide etwas genommen und eingenommen?
Na ja, ich habe dann so ein bisschen Hustensaft genommen.
Den so in Drogerie mag ich, aber das hat überhaupt nicht geholfen.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Ausfluss blühtbemerkt oder blühtfaden?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe da auch nicht so genau geguckt.
Meistens schlucht man das ja doch wieder runter.
Wenn ich es mal ausgespuckt habe, war aber kein Blut dabei. Nein.
Okay.
Denkensü, gibt es dafür bestimmt auch so ein bisschen,
hat es schon erkelten, dann diese Bescheide schlimm angeworden?
Na ja, also ja, vielleicht, fängt das mit so einer leichten Sommererkältung an.
Ja.
Wenn man so einen Husten hat und solche Schmerzen, das kenne ich überhaupt gar nicht.
Okay.
Wann hatten Sie diese Erkältung für das Waldbuchen oder?
Na, nee, das vielleicht so 10 Tage her oder so.
Okay.
Wollen Sie deswegen beim Hausarzt oder sind Sie...
Ja, das ist ein Erkältung, das geht ja nicht zum Hausarzt, das macht man ja eigentlich.
Ja, okay.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie zu Bescheiden verhindert oder verschlechtert?
Zum Beispiel, kalte Wetter oder nachtemessen?
Wir haben jetzt keinen teilsen Wetter, das ist ja eher warmes Wetter.
Und da habe ich das Gefühl, der geht mir gar nicht gut.
Und was ich merke, so nachts kann ich nicht gut schlafen,
weil ich immer so Husten muss.
Und ich habe mir jetzt schon mal ein Wett ein bisschen hochgestellt,
den Rückenteil, dass ich nachts nicht so diese Atemnot habe.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine?
Geschwollene Beine habe ich nicht.
Nee, Husten habe ich.
Okay.
Und ist diese Bechwärde so erst mal aufgetreten oder hatten Sie schon ernebt?
So, was ist die Art mit solchen Husten und solchen Schmerzen?
Nee, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Noch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch weitere Bechwärde, zum Beispiel Herstrasen oder Gliederschmerzen?
Nee, das eigentlich nicht.
Aber Sie haben ja gefragt, ob ich da in dem Schleimblut war, was ich hatte.
Ich habe so ein bisschen eine Schnumpenase und da hatte ich einmal ordentlich Nasenbluten,
aber nur ein einziges Mal.
Okay.
Jetzt würde ich gerne über Ihre Folgeste etwas wissen.
Leiden Sie an die Wand verschen vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, also, ich weiß seit fünf Jahren, dass ich so zu Gicht neige.
Und vor fünf Wochen hatte ich mal einen richtigen Gicht-Anfall mit dem Großzehngelenk.
Das ist fünf Wochen her.
Dann habe ich eigentlich schon ewig lange immer Rückenschmerzen.
Das habe ich schon fast 15 Jahre.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Sache, wo ich jetzt im Sommer bei der Sonnenbestrahlung aufpassen muss.
Ich habe hier im Schleifenbereich so eine Hautveränderung, die bei Sonne sich bemerkbar macht.
Und da muss ich dann aufpassen, dass ich da wirklich wenig Sonne abträge.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie auf Regangestikmedikamentat?
Ja, ich nehme regelmäßig Zylurik 300.
Zylurik habe ich richtig gut.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und dann dieses komische Gelder wegen der Hautveränderung.
Das nehme ich nur im Sommer, einmal morgens und einmal mittags.
Wenn dich das dann örtlich daran.
Ja, gegen Hautveränderung. Sie haben gesagt, wegen dieser Hautveränderung bei Sonne.
Sonne? Was nehmen Sie da?
Das heißt Zola Ratze Gel.
Zola Ratze Gel.
Okay.
Und wurden Sie ein bisschen operiert?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich mal schon lange her.
Ich habe schon lange her so eine Kapaltunnel-Operation gehabt.
An der rechten Hand.
Rechter.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Afrika?
Sonst, ich glaube, nicht gut oder?
Normalerweise ist es sehr gut.
Also meine 90 kg habe ich nicht von ungefähr.
Ich habe nicht so viel zu tun, aber ich fühle mich wirklich schlecht.
Ja.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit angewischt?
Nein, ich fühle mich sehr schlecht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Wasserblasenprobleme?
Oder Sturrgang?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe manchmal ein bisschen Blähung, aber richtig Sturrprobleme oder Probleme beim Wasserblasen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Beleihung.
Das habe ich eigentlich schon ewig lange.
Seit ich erwachsen bin.
Ja, ich darf tatsächlich keinen Amoxicillin nehmen.
Amoxicillin.
Wie ist das mit der Allergie?
Da habe ich so einen Ausschlag von bekommen.
So ein roter Pünktchen, so einen Hautauschlag.
Ich habe das schon lange.
Ja, ich rauche nicht viel, so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag nur.
Aber jetzt schon ganz schön lange, eigentlich seit ich 19 bin.
Seit ich 19 bin, nehm ich mich, rauche ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe das schon lange.
Seit ich 19 bin, nehm ich mich, rauche ich ein halbes Päckchen am Tag.
Halbes Päckchen.
Okay.
Wegen der Axis-Propbleme, ich habe vielleicht falsch verstanden.
Ich möchte sicherlich,
mit 19 oder seit 19 Jahren.
Also seit ich 19 Jahre alt bin, also seit 38 Jahren.
Seit 38 Jahren rauche ich.
Okay.
Und ja,
trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, also
viel Alkohol trinke ich eigentlich nicht.
Sagen wir mal,
abends ein Bier zum Abendbrot oder
jetzt, wenn man draußen auf der Terrasse sitzt,
noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ja,
kleine Mengen.
Zeglisch.
Ja, fast jeglich, würde ich sagen.
Seit wann?
Seit ich erwachsen bin, also viele Jahre schon.
Okay.
Und bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht,
weil es eine reine Routine-Prage ist.
Ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Drogen.
Okay.
Sie haben auf der aktuellen Bescheid,
hat ich auch weitere Fragen.
Sie haben bei uns eine Schmerzen.
Diese Schmerzen,
wie beschweren Sie das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich würde Sie als Brennend beschreiben,
vielleicht.
Ja, also, so
brennende, brennende, stechenende Schmerzen beim Husten.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
und da zumindest planetäre Schmerzen?
Ja, das kann ich wirklichiv מצ bösen.
Doch, das ist nicht die母 confused.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
sondern ich habe den Schmerzen.
Ja, aber ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
Haben Sie eine Lymphknotenschwellung bemerkt in Ihrem Heißbereich oder anderen Körperteilen?
Was ist geschwollen?
Lymphknotenschwellung.
Eine Lymphknotenschwellung?
Lymph oder eine Putti.
Eine Lymphknotenschwellung.
Ich kenne mich nicht mit aus, weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich jetzt aber nicht bemerkt, dass irgendetwas geschwollen ist.
Okay.
Herr Port, jetzt, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite als Flurist in einem großen Blumengestecht.
Ist gut.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Drei Kinder.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ein Kind hat das Downsyndrom.
Da haben wir natürlich ein bisschen Sorgen, wie das alles weitergeht.
Ja, ich kann Sie verstehen, ja.
Ich bin sehr leid, ja.
Und ja, treiben Sie Sportregel misco, oder?
Haben Sie das gesagt?
Ja, meistens komme ich da nicht dazu.
Meistens komme ich da nicht dazu.
Ich fahre vielleicht mal mit dem Fahrrad irgendwo, oder am Wochenende.
Aber normalerweise so richtig aktiv Sport betreibe ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Und in Ihrem Familie gibt es wichtige Vorallklungen.
Also mein Vater, der hat im Bergbau gearbeitet, der hat eine Staublunge.
Aber das ist ja, hängt ja mit seiner Arbeit zusammen.
Und meine Mutter, die ist eigentlich auch noch relativ fit,
aber die hatte jetzt vor vier Wochen eine Darmooperation.
Die hatte einen Darmserschluss.
Und dann haben wir natürlich erstmal große Angst gehabt, aber der geht jetzt wieder ganz gut.
Gott sei Dank, ja.
Herr Pol, okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nee, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Ja Herr Pol, ich habe Ihnen alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Möchtest du Sie etwas zufügen oder etwas zu fragen?
Nein, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen kann.
Sie haben mir so viel gefragt und ich habe so viel erzählt.
Ja.
Ich möchte jetzt eigentlich nur, dass es mir endlich besser geht,
dass dieser Husten aufhört und dass ich mich nicht mehr so ehlend fühle.
Okay. Könntest du es bitte wiederholen?
Ich habe jetzt keine Fragen.
Ich möchte nur, dass man keine Beschwerden aufhört.
Ich möchte nicht so viel hupen und dass man mehr vertrackt wird.
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Pol, wir sind für Sie da.
Wir können uns sehr besten für Sie machen.
Ja.
Aber erst, weil wir unsere Koopalische und Tarzuka,
das ist sehr wichtig.
Und gegebenen Fall kann ich auch sein,
sein Stoff geben.
Ja, macht das nicht,
Ja, wie möchte ich das?
Okay, dann verstehe ich das.
Okay, dann bittes ich und ich komme gleich.
Momentan, leider kann ich Ihnen das hören.
Ist wieder die Verbindung schlecht?
Ja, ja, das ist ein richtig Problem.
Die ganze Zeit? Ist das schon die ganze Zeit?
Am Lester-Seit, nicht ganz der Seite.
Am der letzten Seite habe ich mich sehr gut gehalten.
Haben die anderen auch Probleme?
Herr Gemüs, können Sie auch mich nicht hören?
Ja, Lester-Seit, wir hören nicht.
Ja, da müssen Sie irgendwie Zeichen geben,
oder mir sagen, dass Sie mich nicht hören.
Ist es jetzt wieder besser?
Ja, jetzt besser.
Nun steige ich einmal aus. Ich kann ja einmal aussteigen und wieder einsteigen.
Soll ich das eben machen?
Dann gehe ich einmal raus und komme wieder, momentan.
Nein, jetzt bin ich.
Ich mache einmal neu, ich bin kurz weg.
Und dann komme ich wieder.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Keiner will etwas lesen.
Können wir als Alsatsgeschef anfangen?
Ja, okay.
Guten Tag Frau Berastin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne diesen Patient in Ihnen vorstellen.
Hatten Sie dafür sein?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, ich habe die
dass er für sieben Tage eine Erfärzung gehabt habe.
Ja, und auf Erberichtete von Renitis und Erhaben einmal,
Epi-Taxis. Die vegetive Anamnese ist unaufwollt, bis auf
die äh
die
Ich habe mich mit der Erleichter-Allergie und der Bekommendau aufgemacht.
Ja, ich habe ihn schon gemacht.
Ich habe ihn schon gemacht.
Und ich habe mich auch von der
Ich habe die Stimme von Silikosis verheiratet.
Und seine Mutter, leider seine Mutter,
habe von fünf Wochen Helios gelitten.
Aber ja, ging es ihnen wieder besser.
Er habe keine Geschwister.
Ich habe drei Kinder, eine von ihnen habe Down syndrome.
Und aufgrund der Anamnestischen Angabe,
ich habe von Pneumonia auf,
Bakterielepneumonia auf.
Und als Differenzial Diagnose,
und Akutebronschitis,
Bronschalkarsenum,
vielleicht in Betracht.
Das ist nicht so, ja, aber es kann sein.
Ja, und meine Mutter,
die ist auch von der Diagnose,
die ist auch von der Diagnose.
Ja, und meine Diagnose,
die ist auch von der Diagnose,
der ist auch von der Diagnose.
Was erwarten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, ich erwarte,
Erhöfte Atemkriegens.
Er ist für die Menschen, die hier verraten,
die Parapartiere, die die Menschen
verraten, die sich an den
Menschen verraten.
Er ist für die Menschen, die
die Menschen verraten.
Ja, und ja, ich inspektiere auch in den Mund.
Ja, Pilag obereweg, infektion als Ushilis.
Ich spüre eine Toraxite.
Was machen Sie denn im Labor zusätzlich zu den Blutuntersuchungen?
Zuntersichtlich zu den Blutuntersuchungen.
Was machen Sie im Labor?
Ja, vielleicht, ich werde auch um den Dimmer veranlassen.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine Blutuntersuchung.
Ich meine, hier ist doch etwas anderes. Was untersuchen Sie noch?
Ja, vielleicht Sprometri, oder Broncoscopie.
Ich meine, was Sie im Labor untersuchen außer dem Blut?
Ich habe gesagt, Schubutumkultur, oder?
Ach so, ja, genau. Haben Sie schon gesagt, habe ich überhört?
Ja, ja, ja, ich habe schon gesagt.
Dann habe ich das überhört. Sorry, Entschuldigung.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, vielleicht,
habe ich ein bisschen Schnelligkeit.
Ja, und dann, ja, dann haben Sie jetzt gesagt, Sie machen Röntgen Torax.
Was erwarten Sie beim Röntgen Torax?
Ich erwarte Interfration,
vielleicht Interfration oder Fliberal Ergos.
Es könnte sein, ja,
Leberpynomene, interstziale Phenomekanische,
mit Hilfe von Röntgen Torax, und Darcheiden.
Okay, gut.
Wenn sich Ihre Annahme, Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigt,
was machen Sie da mit den Patienten?
Ja, das hängt ab,
Algemeinzustand und Schwergrad von Symptome,
ja, ich werde nach Unterzugsbefunde
in Schaden,
ich werde nach Unterzugsbefunde in Schaden.
Aber bei Schwerren,
werde ich stationale Aufnahme entfeyeln.
Ja, das ist, dafür gibt es einen Skala,
CRP, Konfusion oder
Atm-Frequenz,
und Blutdruck.
Und dann
Reverte,
und
Handschubwerk.
Ah, okay, ja.
Und
Ober-65 Jahre alt, ja.
Aber das ist der, ich bin ja noch 57.
Der ist ja 57.
Ja, 57, ja.
Und deswegen, ja, ich habe schon gesagt,
vielleicht, ich werde auch Saustürzaktikons messen.
Vielleicht kann ich je nach Algemeinzustand
und Befunde etwas entscheiden.
Ja, genau.
Und was machen Sie, wenn Sie die Institution ja aufgenommen haben?
Ja, ich werde erst
in der
Sehr gut.
Sehr gut. Okay, super. Ja.
Ja, ich glaube, sie sind mehr.
So ja, und dann haben sie ja schon gesagt, sie wollen Sauerstoffsättigung checken
und gegebenenfalls eben U2 geben, ne?
Ja, also es ist alles gekommen, was in Frage kommt.
Würde ich sagen, untersuchen Sie mal Ihren Patienten und halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
was dabei rausgekommen ist, ob der wirklich eine Pneumonie hat.
Und natürlich machen wir bei der Visite dann eine Kurvenbesprechung.
Und schauen, wie es dem Patienten geht. Alles klar.
Gut, wunderbar.
Ja.
Und eine Erklärung?
Nein, nur einfach jetzt. Sie kümmern sich jetzt um Ihren Patienten.
Wir sind fertig, ja?
Wir haben das ja schön gemacht. Heute fand ich es sehr gut.
Ja.
Also besonders schön fand ich wieder das Gespräch mit dem Patienten,
weil sie immer sehr zugewandt sind, mit Namen ansprechen.
Und wenn er erzählt von dem Kind, dass sie gesagt haben,
oh ja, das ist sicherlich schwer.
Also haben sie toll gemacht, so Zuwendung gezeigt und so, ne?
Und ich fand auch im Arztgespräch,
dass man von den technischen Problemen, die wir hatten, ein bisschen absieht,
war das wirklich richtig gut.
Ja, haben sie heute sehr schön gemacht.
Dankeschön.
Ja.
Das gibt mir Mut.
Danke.
Ich bin überrascht, dass es so viele Leute da sind heute Abend.
Ich habe gedacht, heute Abend kommt keiner,
sitzen alle irgendwo draußen oder im Haus und sagen,
boah, los, nicht jetzt arbeiten.
Weil es so schrecklich heiß ist, ja.
Aber ja, haben wir doch wieder volles Haus gehabt,
viele Leute, ja, sehr schön.
Danke.